digamos que tenemos una variable
aleatoria x que quizás representa la
estatura de una persona elegida
aleatoriamente o algo por el estilo
aquí tenemos su distribución de
probabilidad que aquí dibujé como una
curva de campana o una distribución
normal pero que puede ser otra
distribución cualquiera también dibuje
en la media de esta distribución una
desviación estándar por encima de la
media y una desviación estándar por
debajo de la media lo que vamos a hacer
en este vídeo será analizar cómo se ven
afectadas la media y la desviación
estándar de una distribución de
probabilidad cuando se suma o se escala
esta variable aleatoria veamos qué
sucede si tenemos otra variable
aleatoria llamada ye que es igual a lo
que sea igual
la variable aleatoria x más una
constante que de notaremos con una k
minúscula esta no es una variable
aleatoria es una constante podría ser el
número 10 estas son las estaturas de
personas elegidas aleatoriamente y a eso
le agregamos 10 centímetros
quizá porque nos interesa ver la
distribución de las estaturas de las
que usan sombreros de copa' o algo así
cómo afectará esto a la media y a la
desviación estándar de iu en su relación
con x cómo se verá la distribución de g
en lugar de que la media o el centro de
la distribución esté aquí se va a
desplazar acá a la derecha de hecho
podemos desplazar toda la distribución
hacia la derecha cada unidades en este
ejemplo imaginamos que acá es bastante
grande y queda así cambiamos de color
para indicar que esta es la distribución
de probabilidades para la variable
aleatoria ya pueden ver que la
distribución solamente se ha desplazado
hacia la derecha en que la media se
movió a la derecha más cara se movería a
la izquierda si fuera menos acá esto
claramente afecta a la media ahora la
media será acá más grande lo escribimos
podemos decir que la media de nuestra
variable aleatoria
es igual a la media de la variable
aleatoria x más acá lo pueden ver en la
gráfica pero cambia en la desviación
estándar
que la desviación estándar es una forma
de medir la dispersión típica a partir
de la media y eso no cambia para la
variable aleatoria x esta longitud es
una desviación estándar que será igual
que la desviación estándar acá de
nuestra variable aleatoria y podemos
decir que la desviación estándar de la
variable aleatoria allí es igual que la
desviación estándar de la variable
aleatoria x aquí pueden ver que el sumar
una constante a una variable aleatoria
afecta a su media pero no afecta a su
desviación estándar qué pasaría si
escalamos una variable aleatoria digamos
que tenemos otra variable aleatoria que
llamamos zeta y que es igual a una
constante k que multiplica a x recuerden
que acá no es una variable aleatoria
sino que representa un número cualquiera
pensemos en lo que sucede aquí vamos a
dibujar de nuevo la distribución de
nuestra variable aleatoria x sica es
igual a 2 vamos a tener esta
distribución escalada o estirada por 2 y
ya
el área total siempre tiene que ser
igual a 1 esta distribución se va a
aplanar con una escala de 2 para
conservar la misma área podemos hacer
esto con nuestra herramienta de dibujo
vamos a hacerla más corta con un factor
de 2 y la vamos a estirar por el mismo
factor permítanme alinear los ejes para
que podamos apreciar esto va a lucir
algo así así queda la distribución de
nuestra variable aleatoria z le ponemos
el color correspondiente aquí podemos
ver dos cosas la primera es que la media
se ha desplazado la media se escalo la
segunda es que vemos que las
desviaciones estándar también se han
escalado la desviación estándar de z se
ha escalado y no sólo eso sino que se ha
escalado en un factor de k esto es igual
a k que multiplica a la desviación
estándar de x también vemos que la media
de la variable aleatoria z es igual a k
por la media de x así que en resumen si
tenemos una variable aleatoria que se
construye al sumarle a una cosa
a otra variable aleatoria va a desplazar
la media con esta constante pero no va a
afectar la desviación estándar si
escalamos o multiplicamos una variable
aleatoria por una constante para obtener
otra variable aleatoria entonces nos va
a afectar tanto a la media como a la
desviación estándar